les casseurs ont ils tué le mouvement
des gilet jaune voilà vous le savez on a
vu lors du 18ème acte beaucoup beaucoup
de violence des incendies des pillages
organisés par des black blocks mais qui
sont-ils pourquoi font-ils ça l'un d'eux
a accepté de répondre à nos questions en
exclusivité il ya eu un déferlement de
violence qui est très très lourd en
conséquence pour le mouvement des gilet
jaune le aujourd'hui c'est la première
fois que le mouvement des gels et jaune
passe en dessous des 50% de d opinions
favorables à la chaux dit le
gouvernement a décidé d'interdire les
manifestations à certains endroits aussi
et les français donc je voulais dit le
thé soutiennent de moins en moins et
c'est regrettable pour certains qui se
battent pour l'horreur ont leur idée
selon vous les casseurs ont ils tué le
mouvement je vous propose qu'on voit à
premier extrait de l'interview du black
block
on lui a demandé d'abord de nous
expliquer ce qu'était un black bloc et
comment ils procéder parce que c'était
important pour nous de savoir et vous
montrer ce qu'est un black bloc parce
qu'on en entend tout le temps parler et
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à les définir
garde manifestation qui utilisent des
méthodes d'action directe et le
pacifique ont deux préfèrent nous
appelons tranquille et les militants des
activistes ont pris des notes
c'est plusieurs doutes qui s'agrège
jouer ensemble et changer pour former un
bloc et dont nous c'est souvent des
groupes qui ont des affinités sont
politiques
c'est très diversifié donc moi autant de
jeunes que personne ne peut présager
pour les idées politiques ce sont des
groupes qui s'agrège donc on n'aura pas
de tout ce qui m'amuse et des politiques
et on peut pas nous dire on sait tous
des a marché c'est tous des communistes
c'est tous destinés aux fesses mais
c'est impossible de dire ça c'est très
bien qu'amoureux de la mouvance anarcho
autonome c'est évident mais après c'est
pas toutes les personnes qui se
connaissaient avant même les
antispécistes pour une journée d'action
s'il aurait cru les déforme les
différentes personnes qui viennent
participer aux manifestations ont des
fonctions particulières c'est à dire des
personnes qui montrent moins présents
tonton façon ferme et nombre d'autres
personnes qui ont ce tournoi un peu plus
derrière pour un peu sur eux et lancé
des musiques pour conserver ses
lectrices aujourd'hui il est alors les
black blocks ont-ils tuer qu'ils tuent
et le mouvement des gilet jaune
maxime qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
déjà à bassa c'est une bonne question
est ce que ça alors ce garçon il faut
savoir je vous dis ils étaient tous
présents sur les champs elysées il a la
vingtaine il est étudiant en master de
lettres
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ben moi je vous dis tionnement ça va
tuer le mouvement est ce que est ce que
vous en côtoyer est-ce que je côtoie des
black blocks personnellement non j'ai
pas de black blocks dans mon entourage
quand vous les voyez sur les
manifestations et est ce que vous
essayez de donner d'aller leur parler
d'essayer des données ou pas du tout
venant et aucun contact avec eux non
j'ai discuté avec certains black blocks
après j'ai fait la différenciation entre
les black blocks et les casseurs j'ai vu
des gars péter des vitrines pour vider
ce qu'il y avait dedans et j'ai vu des
black blocks qui faisait face aux forces
de l'ordre
quand il y avait des charges pour éviter
que les gens qui se faisait gaz et/ou
chargé et les personnes qui étaient les
plus faibles ceux face à lui mais la
tronche alors vous quand vous voyez des
ce qui s'est passé samedi dernier
vous dites pas que les casseurs sont en
train de tuer le mouvement puisque vous
avez vu que vous êtes passé voilà les
gilets jaunes sont soutenus maintenant
par moins de 50% des gens alors que au
départ j'aurais vous étiez parti vous
êtes c'était 90 les chiffons parce que
les chiffres si on les écoute mouvement
devrait durer une semaine
oui ça fait suer semaine si on les
écoute on serait à découvert de gilet
jaune parce que tous les week-ends y en
a de moins en moins il ya deux mois on
était à 7000 ou 8000 et puis tous les
week-ends on perd 10 20% qui en fait on
est toujours c'est tout et les casseurs
avec un échange malgré son moitié plein
les casseurs ils vous font beaucoup de
mal
les casseurs c'est une façon de
s'exprimer que moi je vous condamne et
n'aurait jamais passé autant d'années ça
vous n'aurez les rayons ses paquetages
condamnés jusque dans le pas parce qu'en
fait j'ai des deux côtés mais vous
voulez vous expliquer tout de suite
partir je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
d'instinct côté si je veux condamner les
casseurs sait jamais il faut aussi qu'on
dernier le gouvernement
je vous explique pourquoi je veux bien
condamner les casseurs parce que moi je
trouve que c'est un mode de d'expression
qui est pas le mien et qui ne correspond
pas y'a pas de problème
j'avais déjà vous d
vous êtes déjà surpris à voilà à faire
agresser quelque chose oui oui non moi
j'y vais visage découvert voilà j'ai eu
des grands parce que il a dans la foi
chapeau messieurs j'ai mis un casque et
j'aimerais bien finir parce qu'ils aient
du mal à laisser finir les gens aussi on
aimerait bien vous finirez parce que je
suis pas prêt d'arrêter
et puis est dans une dictature qu'on
fait taire les gens qui sont pas
d'accord avec sans merci s'il vous plaît
et donc pour finir ouais je condamne les
violences mais des deux côtés ça veut
dire que ça fait 40 ans que le
gouvernement est violent avec les gens
psychologiquement financièrement ça
amène des dizaines de milliers de
personnes à tuer chaque année et s'il
n'y avait pas ça il y aurait personne
dans les rues s'il y avait une réponse
politique dès le départ il y aurait
personne dans les rues mais s'il y avait
une justice sociale
il y aurait personne dans les rues mais
vous voyez bien que toi mon acte ii les
fixes que vous aurez peut-être rejoints
peut-être alors peut-être alors est ce
qu'on a vécu à l'acte ii y avait plus
personne qu'avant il rejoint peut-être à
corps à moitié mais je n'en mets 13e
tout sera celle très intéressant la
skoda temps des maximes parce que ça ça
c'est très intéressant c'est qu'ils ont
deux cas aujourd'hui
non mais vous dites vous avez un certain
temps mais ils se font pas l'amalgamé
non plus entre ceux qui pètent et qui
s'en prennent aux forces de l'ordre et
ceux qui pètent pas compte des
revendications nord par exemple il y
aurait jamais taper sur la gueule d'un
flic par exemple non bien sûr mais par
contre on a vu défiler jeune femme est
donneur au black block sur le bien sûr
voilà c'est ça qu'on a vu et ça vous
avez aussi à fait inadmissible civile et
gilet jaune éteindre des incendies
oui mais aussi vu défiler et l'accident
tout maxime il ya le fait voir défiler
chose faire une haie d'honneur à des
black blocks c'est inadmissible arrêté à
mais je suis d'accord mais applaudir un
président qui qui a pourri son peuple et
qu'il faut dans la merde tous les jours
je trouve ce d'état tous les jours ne la
cautionne pas mais je suis pas là
applaudir tous et quelle violence d'état
vous voyez des coups moi ma coup il
vient pas chez moi non mais la violence
est pas forcément maintenant mais je ne
vous avez une étudiante de 18 ans kg de
sucre aussi la presse écrite c'est pas
mieux l'arrêter mais moi je progresse à
cinq enfants je vis dans la cité vous
avez pas me faire le côté du
misérabilisme
là vous êtes là vous avez fait des
revendications par les dépôts ils sont
forts ils ont trouvé la seule personne
au rsa qui aiment le gouvernement
je finis ainsi bouclée parce que je vais
vous dire tous les complots partout ça
c'est une question d'état d'esprit tout
simplement
- effectivement moi la seule chose que j
sais que c'est pas un gouvernement
d'assumer mes choix
effectivement j'ai pas été à l'école
effectivement j'ai pas diplôme c'est la
faute à mâcon c'est pas la faute à
maquereau aujourd'hui moi ce que je
demande c'est d'avoir un pays qui me
donne les moyens de travailler eh ben je
vais vous étonner mais je travaille
quand je place pour des raisons vous
avez cinq enfants
oui là pour des raisons médicales suite
à une grossesse mes enfants sont nés
prématurés donc et tantôt trois auto
entrepreneurs de savoir qu'on n'est pas
cotisations chômage n'ont donc je me
suis retrouvé au rsa envoyé
auto-entrepreneurs rsa la chute elle est
là et bien et au même et je dis merci la
france si j'avais pas le rsa si j'avais
pas les allocations familiales
je serai où je serai dehors j'aurais
même pu de logements et boum il ya
certains qui sont au rsa ou la liseuse
qui peuvent pas sortir dit il faut aussi
prendre le coup en compte que le rsa est
de s'effacer dans une situation d je
suis d'accord mais il ya déjà tu ne
peuvent pas sortir de ses chaînes fini
je finis pas c'est là qu'on maintient là
moi je veux un pays qui me donne la
possibilité effectivement de ce nom dans
la même rubrique actu et plancha la
voyez vous avez des mêmes revendications
exactement ce qu'il vous a dit gionta
non mais elle déteste les gilet jaune
gasquet elle est notre façon avec la
violence pourquoi vous ne combat pas
alors c'est auprès eric naulleau boîtier
de vougy résonneront matin c'est ok on
se cale gilet jaune en entendant la ce
soir vous êtes le représentant des gis
je représente pas léger léger hop et
maxime s'il vous plaît madame à
l'avenant eric naulleau voo tv
l'étiquette qui vous arrange bien joué
si les gens me suivent et gilet jaune a
d'autres aussi qu eric naulleau antonio
qu'elle à eric naulleau maxime nicole
nous a expliqué plusieurs choses
notamment expliqué que les black blocks
en fait ce sont des anges gardiens qui
protège les populations les plus faibles
c'est pas ce qui apparaît sur les images
mais c'est sa vision à lui attend sur
l'ambiguïté total c'est que en fait
maxime nicole a besoin des casseurs les
gilet jaune que le tue lui représente
parle pas de gilet jaune en général mais
le genre de gilet jaune il faut gilet
jaune qu'il représente ont besoin des
casseurs et et le mouvement va se
terminer là dedans puisque maintenant
les vrais gilet jaune servent de
boucliers humains aux casseurs les flics
hausse pas y aller parce que ils veulent
pas aller sur les vrais sur les vrais
gilet jaune il avait fait une
manifestation non jeu
j'ai beaucoup apprécié j'en ai fait des
manifs ou été annoncée mais on n'est pas
là pour parler de mon cv on n'est pas
allé vous bas il ya tout le temps un
double jeu n'a pas expliqué une femme
juste parce que je sais pas ce que c'est
je vous justifiez la colonne manif se
passe vous justifiez erika soeur et vous
utilisez ce qui a dû tilt chez l'un et
chez l'autre donc vous vous êtes dans le
double langage vous êtes dans
l'ambiguïté dans la fosse un paiement
vous dire tout ce qu'il fait ou jamais
alors mais là on est pour moi l'art de
parler des moyens d'action je me dis que
c'est pas le bon moyen de râler parce
que vous utilisez des délinquants pour
faire un registre mais s'il vous plaît
j'aimerais y compris les condamnez vous
les condamne maxime eric gérets couvre
notre extrême violence des deux côtés il
vous faut quoi comme phrase j'aimerais
qu'on voit un autre ex de navires de ce
que je viens de dire est double langage
toujours à 12 mois si vous interprétez
langage nous on a fait une manifestation
10500 pas une bombe lacrymo jeté 1 alors
ça je dirais alors du baldy nous parle
des foulards ou s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît beaucoup
c'est tous les ans fils et une raisons
d'aimer mon avis il est si sérieux non
géré à tous en même temps
andré bercoff devrait venir se
contentant de découvrir le côté
stalinien d'eric naulleau intéressant
c'est vrai que toi bien et est très axé
la révolution c'est un jeune a étonné en
première six mois avant moi il y à des
adultes il ya des crétins et il fait
attention
vraiment moi je dis qu'est ce qui s'est
passé qu'est ce que c'est que les gilets
jaunes et son 11ème revenant au four
juste un bond de cession non mais la
question c'est est-ce que les casseurs
ou tu es de mauvaise moi je dis non
pourquoi ce que les casseurs sont
exactement au gilet jaune ce que le
bordel est un amour quai les casseurs se
sont que le modèle et affonter mal amour
à l'amour à l'amour ce sont des fouteurs
de merde c'est classique
on fait ça on s'en prend aux outils du
capitalisme aux apprend aux institutions
et ses plus hauts ce kiosque était de
finir c'est pas nouveau les black blocks
ça fait des années c'est évidemment déjà
tous non non c'est pas nouveau on y va
leur plaire andré bercoff laisser le
finir par leur tout ce qui est tout ce
qui est institution au capital it tout
ça le faux quel symbole des riches et
tout ça mais j'ai une jeune cyril
hanouna tout ce qui s'est passé ces
violences tout ça c'est très marrant
quand c'était dans les banlieues quand
c'était dans les cités car c'étaient les
petites villes
on n'en parlait pas on n'avait rien à
cirer mais alors ils viennent chez nous
aux champs-elysées mais ça pas du tout
la route en banlieue mais c'est le
gouvernement
oui moi que ça que ça a tué ouais gérez
vous le dis j'ai tout simplement c'est
qu'au départ les ondes indication n'ait
touché les jours départ les
revendications on veut que les plus
faibles longues années maintenant si mme
kelly et veste jaune a laissé lui finir
de madame simone distribution des
richesses
vous étiez tous pour payer oui bien au
regard des enjeux qui finissent aux
artistes rêvés c'est aussi alors bernard
chevry au gouvernement mais figurer le
parlement vous n'êtes pas d'ailleurs
mais ce qu'il a dit ou bien vous dire
que ça a baissé
ça c'est une évidence pourquoi parce que
80 % des gens supposés les gilet jaune
aujourd'hui on est à 45 artistes et ça
montre tout simplement effectivement que
ça nuit et aux revendications et sa nuit
je dirais que j'ai l'idée à la force
qu'un con il s'agissait au départ mais
qui les options si je vous dis une chose
d'acquis jd je suis d'accord avec ces
conneries dans le chercher à faire de
bonnes chances de 15 sur le fait qu'il
va faire après je fais un axe fort match
incroyable vous allez je suis d'accord
il avait capitalisé que vous cherchez je
te tutoyer pas sur le palais telle pente
quand il dit que tu cherches tout à
faire du buzz moi je te connais pas et
je regarde effectivement comme tout le
monde tu crois que ça aura été plus
malins ne dire effectivement je veux les
revendications des gilets jaunes
j'aimais fait distancer drôlerie à eton
ces violences etc
moi je vais passer devant vous allez me
suis alors on va revendiquer de façon on
va faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de
violences par contre changer sauf que
non vous êtes double jeu alors ça vous
plaît beaucoup plus grand si vous avez
dit moi je suis les jours je suis chez
moi on va arrêter sa part été conférés
je sais que je me tiens pas d'accord
avec ami karim sait que dans ce genre
d'émission il faut que vous veniez il
faut que vous vous étiez en mêlée j'ai
une réponse à vous dire ça et c'est pour
ça que je suis au myanmar
le ministre des communications en france
numérique au 10 mai éric numérique
tandis cet acte je vais envoyer des
messages pour lui dire attention ce
week-end ya des gens qui veulent monter
en violences se seraient bien peut-être
de descendre un peu la grâce à l'instant
poste 1 entre autres et pendant 17
semaines je me suis retrouvé sur un
plateau de télé avec lui où il a discuté
où on est tombé d'accord tous les deux
qu'il fallait désescalade et tout ça
parce que ça finirait mal on l'a vu aux
champs-elysées ce week-end la réponse du
gouvernement il s'est fait démonter par
l'elysée il a pu le voir me parle et qui
veut alors arrêter la relance
on va parler dans la nasa va parler
d'agression en a plein de choses à faire
les casseurs actuellement il aura les
interviews vous voulez je vous montrerai
les messages des encore on a tous les
appels ce que j'enregistrais là vous
allez nous en parler et vous voulez
aller à l'elysée disent quoi voulez que
j'aille à l'elysée moi alors pourquoi
est ce que voulait l'europe prochain à
l'elysée ne pas deux comme vous ne qu'on
a péché à mounir majidi de vous parler à
ce que vous allez parce que j'ai aussi
des échanges avec matignon ce que vous
savez matignon nous avait contactés pour
une délégation à bruxelles à aller les
voir
non c'est plus compliqué que ça c'est
pas qu'on a refusé sur le fond parce
qu'on voulait y aller on a refusé parce
que on leur a demandé que ce soit
retransmis en direct pour chaque citoyen
puisse voir ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
donc j'ai les messages avec anne claire
qui est la secrétaire du premier
ministre et qui nous a dit clairement
banon on refuse de retransmettre en
direct
je lui dis bah écoutez je ne serais pas
là puisque si c'est pas retransmis en
direct
j'ai pas vocation à décider pour les
autres elle m'a dit est ce que je peux
vous appeler elle m'a appelée et
finalement elle m'a dit c'est pas
négociable c'est soit vous venez sans
caméra sauve n'est pas en accord avec ce
qu'on avait dit aux gens si c'est pas
retranscrit en direct on n'y va pas on
parlait il ya un instant des casseurs et
ce qu'ils ont tué le mouvement des gilet
jaune et je voulais dit on à en
exclusivité une interview d'un black
block donc ces groupes
voilà qui interviennent dans les
manifestations de manière violente
alors je vais passer un dernier extrait
un extrait un instant qui nous expliquer
ce que c'était et il nous expliquer ce
qui s'était passé samedi dernier avec
toutes les violences qu'on a pu voir
regarde pratiquement
vite et certains médias ont préféré 1500
bloqué ce qui est totalement faux
on est éloquent saint jean du latran 5
un effet d'entraînement au niveau des
juges avec un arrive bien qu en avril
janczyk la place du championnat et ce
qui est assez important de personnes
étaient toujours là on entend que leurs
autres les actionnaires on a participé
aux événements de 5500 ans mais nous
pourrons renverser
et ça c'est les jantes de manifester
l'immeuble est sympa seulement la
violence c'est aussi être dernier la
désobéissance c'est être dans le non
respect des lois le non respect de
l'état dans certains cas et pas
forcément tu es ma maison ça claque les
voilà donc vous l'avez entendu non
respect des lois
le non-respect de l'état il a été assez
clair un ce garçon qu'est ce que vous
voulez réagir eric naulleau à ce que
vous venez d'entendre je propose les
nommés par leurs noms des délinquants un
type qui me dit je veux pas respecter la
loi mais après on peut faire des
périphrases une manière différente de
manifester ce sont des délinquants et je
vois que au sein des idées jaune il ya
50 nuance par rapport aux blacks blocs à
des gens qui en profite
il ya des gens qui les qui les condamne
malheureusement notre invité de ce soir
voilà il est alors sur ce sujet là comme
dans d'autres c'est sylvain lambig on a
on envie blick et au conseil
constitutionnel pardon des délinquants
vont jusqu'au conseil constitutionnel
c'est bien ça c'est quoi les délinquants
jusqu'au conseil d'état je sais pas il
n'a pas été pour rester sur l'essentiel
alors est ce que les verts est-ce que
les casseurs royaume est ce que les
casseurs ont tué le mouvement des jeunes
et j'aimerais me tourné par le maire les
manuels grégoire première adjoint à la
mairie de paris collaborateurs directs
d'anne hidalgo merci d'être avec nous
emmanuel merci emmanuel êtes la fin nous
avons vous êtes favorable à
l'interdiction de manifester samedi et
première question dont vous pensez que
les cas seront tués le mouvement alors
où est ce que vous étiez gilet jaune à
la base parce que vous souteniez le
mouvement voilà peut-être et repartir de
la question est ce que les casseurs ont
tué le mouvement et ne l'ont pas tué
c'est une évidence
en revanche et qu'ils ont changé la
nature du mouvement et je le trouve
décrédibiliser le mouvement la réponse
est pour moi clairement oui pourquoi
parce que dans les premières journées de
mobilisation il y avait un débat qui
était centré sur les revendications
c'était quoi les revendications c'était
le pouvoir d'achat de la justice fiscale
et on pourra appeler du respect de la
considération minimum d'égard de respect
vis-à-vis dans le dialogue social dans
les relations sociales y compris
peut-être dans des formules à tout le
moins maladroite du gouvernement et plus
les journées sont assez gros plus on
s'est éloigné de ce débat pour être je
le regrette profondément
dans une stratégie de confrontation et
de mise en tension et où d'une certaine
manière
moi je trouve que les casseurs ont tué
le mouvement c'est que dans cette
exacerbation de la violence dans le côté
un peu pratique qu'un certain nombre de
manifestants ont trouvé condamnant mais
quand même pas que puisque d'une
certaine manière la violence est un
moyen de médiatiser et dans ces espèces
de romantisme révolutionnaire que je ne
partage pas du tout à ne sommes pas en
1789 ne sommes pas en 1848 et le laisser
à penser est à mon avis un contresens
historique et rendre bien des mauvais
service au débat politique dans le
meilleur des cas c'est ce qu'avait dit
monsieur b record tout à l'heure
notamment parce que ça éloigne de ce qui
devrait être le débat central n'ont pas
de savoir si on doit casser ou pas n'ont
pas de savoir si on doit interdire ou
pas les manifestations et je le redis je
ne suis pas pour interdire les
manifestations surtout pas il y en a
tous les jours et c'est très bien je
suis en revanche totalement contre les
dégradations et ce à quoi nous avons
assisté à paris et jean le débat il
devrait pouvoir se recentrer sur les
questions sociales qui sont portées par
le mouvement des gilets jaunes et dont
je pense ce qui explique en partie
l'adhésion à ses larges majoritaire ou
pas peu importe
en tout cas les revendications
principales telles quelles et déportés
sont soutenus largement et le défaut du
débat aujourd'hui tel qui est engagée
c'est que derrière ces revendications
qui sont un peu générique sert que de
dire qu'on est en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat
ok mais il faudrait pouvoir le creuset
l'approfondir ça veut dire quoi est-ce
qu'on est pour augmenter les salaires
est ce qu'on est pour une meilleure
répartition des richesses
oui dans les politiques sociales rudy
sabatier fait combien d'années les
questions sont posées là tu veux
proposé depuis très longtemps les
vedettes a abandonné vous êtes chaussée
sortir de l'ena fin peut-être pas au
point mais il y en a qui sortent de la
chance j'en entends voilà qu'il fait
c'est souvent sur la complexe mais ça
fait 40 ans qu'ils attendent de trouver
solution énorme parfait c'est une
évidence mais simplement je fais partie
des gens qui pensent et peut-être ne
suis-je pas le seul que c'est par le
débat politique qu'on le met en tension
c'est par les programmes électoraux
qu'on propose des solutions et c'est par
le vote qu'on les arbitre aval après ne
crois pas que ce soit dans la
confrontation violente est donc alors si
vous dites que vous êtes d'accord sur le
fait que ce n'est pas dans la
confrontation
s'il vous plaît photo sur isolant pour
ne pas en arriver là si des lâcheurs
gouvernement avait écouté les
revendications qui était très basique
pouvoir d'achat aucune des privilèges
d'état symétrique en jeu le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
alors et là je fais un global risk dont
on parle beaucoup exactement dans ce
combat qui fait que ça mais juste un mot
pas pourquoi vous vous dites c'est
j'aime bien écouter surtout que vous
êtes à paris
bref beaucoup de choses à dire sur paris
mais c'est pas le sujet vous savez il ya
eu quelque chose ou parler de violence
non violence de retrait et c'est ce qui
me fait un musée
il ya quand même quelque chose je vais
pas remonté à 1789
rassurez vous mais franchement il ya des
leçons à prendre savez on est en 2019 ya
des leçons à prendre d'un certain nombre
de révolutions en france ou de
confrontation
je vous rappelle notre dame des landes 1
on a voté pour les reprendre notre dame
des larmes les indices sont arrivés les
à dist obtenu notre dame des landes
les analystes ont tenu par la violence
connaît me connaît pas et qu'a fait le
gouvernement qui n'était pas suite macro
il a reculé à partir du moment où vous
acceptez que une et un mouvement violent
revendicatif je ne discute pas de la
justesse ou pas assez comment vous
pouvez dire aujourd'hui avec les indices
ont accepté mais là ça ne va plus du
tout savoir ce qu'on veut l'action des
indices parce que les indices de nantes
j'ai pas été pendant que moi mais je me
suis renseigné à l'époque là dessus
comme il y avait deux champs de
permaculture comme il y avait deux
projets citoyen de succomber y avait
deux personnes qui étaient là
quelque chose je suis passé dans votre
pays bien sûr vous avez les réformes
l'homme d'origine citoyenne jamais le
gouvernement d'ailleurs le vrai dire on
a voulu cette europe je suis désolé mais
le référendum dit j'aimerais j'aimerais
qu'on vienne à la question c'est au
plein air andré les casseurs ont calculé
le mouvement guy me mohamed
moi j'ai dit je dis non car les casseurs
représenté par les black box ne sont pas
les gilet jaune
il existe déjà avant les gilet jaune ils
ont strictement rien à faire des jeux
les jouets s'assurer sinon on oublie ce
que c'est c'est en gros des fils à papa
qui ont une situation confortable qui et
blablabla anticapitaliste qui vont
brûler des magasins des points
stratégiques avec une paire de baskets
nike un iphone et puis vont aller au
mcdo derrière et qui derrière peuvent
salir le mouvement ça c'est évident par
contre lorsqu'il ya eu certaines
violences d'un côté comme de l'autre on
les a pas dit tout dénoncer la même
façon on a parlé de cette fameuse zineb
red one qui a reçu une bombe lacrymogène
elle a 80 ans elle est décédée j'ai pas
entendu beaucoup de compassion de la
part du gouvernement même pas un mot
d'excusé is here ils se sont battus à
coups de topsy ou est ce que c'est c'est
ce que s'est passé la même chose vous
avez enchaîné eut un jeune qui a eu la
mâchoire fracturée n'en a pas beaucoup
parlé de moi après ce jeune qui faisait
que s'il a parlé par doro est d'accord à
ce que parce que les maisons tandis
qu'emi on en a pas beaucoup parlé par
contre lorsque le fouquet's brûle là
c'est la république qui tremble et là
tout d'un coup on en voit les militaires
et non mais il faudrait quand même se
dire que demain il y aura des gens armés
avec we cry est pas le réel les ont mis
dans les pattes il se passer
que va-t-il se passer non ils font pas
d'améliorer les liens que vous remplacez
les lieux l'invention qui sont là il est
rare les bâtiments et ceux qui sont à
rennes en arrière ligne ou devant et il
y aura possibilité de contact qui vont à
l'égalité des balles cela les lions vois
les gars et démarre six mois
maintien de l'ordre mais valent elles
s'écoulent et en mettant mieux dire ils
vont être juste pour rire pour remettre
des effectifs maintien de l'ordre à
faire du web un jean question dans ces
cas là est ce que il ya un risque de
contacts n'ont normalement mais avec les
mini chercher c'est la garde
républicaine qu'à l'international
danielle simonnet est ce que vous vous
trouvez que les casseurs ont tué le
mouvement j'aimerais que vous répondez à
la question que vous ne soyez pas sur
les revendications de la france a
soumise dit nous juste est ce que vous
pensez
répondez-moi cette question daniel non
non et d'ailleurs regardez le mouvement
continue après ce qui est vrai est
objectivement je suis profondément
pacifique
ces violences la honda est remis et bien
aux médias dominants de pouvoir traiter
du mouvement des jeunes et jaune que
sous l'angle des violences donc ça bien
servi le système voilà et d'occulter
complètement leurs revendications dont
j'ai parlé ce n'est déjà pas vrai donc
la mission pour autant bah sinon mission
depuis le début de la soirée on parle de
ça mais bon ça n'arrêtait pas de dire
depuis que tu es ce que vous avez déjà
regardé l'émission deuxième non bien sûr
mais je m'appelle la lettonie les médias
car si par contre moi je n'oublie pas
que la première déviance gravissime
c'est la violence sociale qui est
infligé par la politique de ce
gouvernement
on parlait de différents chiffres tout
alors moi j'en donnerai un autre trois
mille personnes qui meurent chaque année
du fait des politiques d'inégalités
sociales morio la rue voilà donc vous
avez saisies mais si ce qu'on dit depuis
daniel mais rien que l'année parlons de
ces violences deux revendications des
gilet jaune au tout début
chasser le mal être de ce que pour moi
les gilet jaune c'était tous les fronts
et ce par tous les français qui étaient
en difficulté cyril hanouna la seule
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
participe à une désescalade de la
violence assez seulement jeux wii alors
orange en deux jours dont gay et l'a
fait la france un service depuis la boue
les encourage et danielle ouimet n'a
jamais en paix
sur le fond geek ou bien chez maier jean
luc mélenchon il interpelle les jeunes
et leur dis attention
ah oui voilà c'est un battant c'est un
peu non c'est notre propos a toujours
été et a été de dire nous sommes en
faveur d'une révolution citoyenne c'est
dans les urnes
in fine et que ça se passera et c'est le
rapport de force de social dans la rue
et ensuite dans les yeux ça se passera
nous avons toujours défendu c'est quoi
une révolution citoyenne sa convocation
d'une assemblée constituante
c'est les citoyens les citoyens qu'ils
puissent redéfinit gauche a légué réduit
sur le feu depuis le début depuis la
gauche mais surtout et humanisme sagat
on n'a pas aujourd'hui tous les ans
parce que vous des magath n'a pas
entendu choper un gâteau de noces qui
n'ont skiba dans ces cas là ce qui est
le président a bien insulté plusieurs
fois les français céderont saab sont pas
je vais dénoncer ici même masque à gaz
agathe daniel rault la corse alors dont
ces symptômes il fait une fois qu'ils
ont cessé de côté les avants toujours
nous la nation pacifique
oui mais ça ça rime et l'huile sur le
feu que dans l'usiné mais vous attisez
vous mettez bull sur le feu daniel
harris et la nina dans la vie dans l'
usage de la violence radicale
il faut savoir que face à nous il ya
toujours une violence d'état qui sera
toujours plus forte donc c'est pas ça la
bonne stratégie mais c'est ce que nous a
remis vous rendez pas service gilet
jaune aussi parfois en mettant de
l'huile sur le feu batoul dit mettons le
temps mis de l'huile sur le web ou les
mollahs est ce que vous avez trouvé 2008
sur le banc parce que vous êtes revenu
une portion plus c'est vrai vous êtes
revenu de propositions succès depuis
quelques temps l'avantagé d'être
position plus neutre
non mais il faut dire il faut dire
d'aller co2 c'est de libérer le
mouvement les moyens mais non les
économies non non pas le nom
et de nous parler des autres médias
daniel cp on n'a pas entendu agathon ses
news neuf jeunes aux formations de nier
le fait que le chaos qui se greffe aux
manifestations et aux rassemblements
populaires depuis le début de ce
mouvement ne dessert pas le mouvement en
lui même c'est évident le message des
vrais gilet jaune ce message de justice
sociale que tu portes mais que tu
portais au départ il devait que je porte
toujours il devient cependant toujours
imité par exemple ça gonfle audible
démarche
je suis d'accord avec toi mais greffe
peau assez inédit parce que bfm tv s'y
passe au nom du team de la condamnent ne
faisons pas du tout avant avant sarandon
une recycling portion de l'autre la
condamnent autrement plus fermement que
toi sans équivoque les vrais gilet jaune
qu'on a reçu l'at on la condamnerait
gilet jaune
les vrais oui les bulles est entre
guillemets eric naulleau tout à l'heure
à sac et attaquer ce qu elle sait pas
sur les attaques sur le fait qu'ils
profitaient du mouvement des jeunes en
essence mettez vous gagnez combien par
mois pour être sur ce plateau
moi je vous savez combien vous savez que
les inconditionnels troc site d'humour
est aussi accro que les semaines les
étoilés en bleu vous êtes qui monsieur
naulleau pour juger de son action qu'est
ce que moi je suis là voté on a le droit
eric naulleau
la libération est aussi depuis une
machine hmi avec maxime nicole qui je le
répète pour moi est un type très
dangereux et un gourou qui profitent de
la situation
donc on exploite la misère des autres il
est soutenu par un avocat qu'ils rient
ya peut-être quelques miettes de buzz à
ramasser ce que genre d'homme à la
profession il est soutenu par une
représentante de la france a soumis ce
qui se dit on est au fond du trou dans
les sondages il faut qu'on se met alors
à qui fait du berger avec vous avez je
vous aime beaucoup mais vous avez un
problème avec la france a soumises
c'est vrai c'est mise non mais vous avez
un problème avec la presse
on a lu alexis cambert aussi vous avez
un problème avec lui vous avoir problème
est que la france ne paie pas tous
auraient besoin la maxime nicole voulait
dire quelque chose sur la france a
souvent oui moi je suis pas politiser du
tout donc on peut peut-être partager des
idées des points mais moi je suis pas
politiser du tout et on n'a pas respecté
ni ne pactise aignan quoique ce sont
actionnés quelqu'un devient le grand
débat quand vous avez lancé vous sur une
plateforme différente qu'à celles du
gouvernement
non mais alors les résultats sont en
train d'être publié là sur les
diffusions répand dans l'axé de la
construction oui mais christine on n'est
pas là dedans là on est sur le premier
sujet c'est des casseurs ont-ils tué le
morceau avant d'un côté maxime karim
zéribi on l'a posé la question à ce
black block aussi la question que tout
le monde se pose est ce que posent tous
les français après avoir vu les images
de samedi dernier ce qui culpabilisent
de voir toutes ces images et de voir
toutes ces violences écoutez sa réponse
certaines personnes n'ont aucune
culpabilité mettre les mots tuent leur
développement en tout cas c'est
difficile que ceux des magasins
moi personnellement c'est une langue en
plus après tout ce qui est matériel
récupéré le même s'il ya des gens qui
travaillent bien alors c'est vrai qu on
détruit mais après ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'une fois le capitalisme donc
l'état
deutsch comptant beaucoup plus fous on
est une famille et au niveau la banque
et l'état une femme de 80 ans mars à
l'étranger personne n'en parle un
capitaliste maisons et tuent des gens
pour le chômage la précarité et on
n'entend pas non plus nous nous sommes
dit à sa mère inaccessibles aux
sauveteurs
on a bien fait pendant des années des
années les manifestations pacifiques ne
fonctionnait pas se font contrôler des
mois entre elle et moi comment ils ont
été les modes d'action plus violent plus
directs ont fonctionné et on pense à
notre dame des landes
on a bien vu qu'il est activé quand la
violence s'est fait face à face et
longuement
si la section ce que le gouvernement
continue malheureusement quant à leur
tour manifesté pendant 80 ans mario
c'est plutôt sinon on est à 100 m
d'actions et dérivés
moi je ne pense pas que les casseurs ont
tué le mouvement des gilet jaune
je pense qu'il l'a il le desservent ils
l'ont affaibli en terme d'image mais ils
ne l'ont pas tué pour la bonne et simple
raison que tant qu'il n'y aura pas de
réponse politique faite aux
revendications initiales le mouvement
perdurera
il faut se le dire après c'est vrai
qu'il ya moins de monde dans la rue et
c'est pas parce qu'il ya moins de monde
dans la rue que dg les jeunes encore une
fois du 17 novembre que j'appellerais
canal historique des retraités qui
étaient jamais sorties de chez eux
quittés et qu'il n'avait jamais été
syndiqué qui pour certains n'ont même
n'ont pas voté ne votaient pas un moment
donné cette souffrance cette colère
s'est pas les blagues box qui veut qui
va qui valent annihiler cette souffrance
ils desservent le moment ça c'est à
l'évidence ils font mal au mouvement
initial populaires légitimes des
citoyens mais ils ne le feront pas il ya
un acteur qui peut faire en sorte tous -
n'existe plus c'est le gouvernement s'il
apporte une réponse de fond
or on lataste réponse de fond il y avait
un grand débat national
il est terminée il est temps que l'on
allait répondre aux retraités qui ne
peut plus avoir les réponses ça c'est le
premier point parce que c'est pas 4 2 ce
casseur ce black des roxy dit très
simple je crois en affichent complet les
deux larges croit la violence est telle
qu'elle se développe aussi canal il faut
le dire même d'un certain johnny la
dirait qu'ils sont marqués par le
mouvement
justement il a dit et simplement une une
chose une chose qui va pas plaire mais
je m'en fous je vous le dis je dis ce
que j'ai envie à deux heures de paris
il ya des gens qui ont fait reculer un
gouvernement qui voulait représenter
pour un cinquième mandat un président
ils étaient des millions dans la rue ils
n'ont rien cassé en alsace
si l'on est cassé vous avez vu sur la
vidéo que c'était j'ai vu de la gouaille
son garçon moi j'étais à la détient
l'algérie ya dix jours j'étais là bas
wen a la manie des étudiants à la fin de
la manif ils ramasser les papiers par
terre
y'a pas une vitrine qui a été péter ils
ont fait le gouvernement c'est un
argument que j'ai beaucoup entendu ça
oui mais oui mais je dis une chose de
cette voie on a fait passer pour des
sauvages sur deux heures de paris c'est
c'est le continent africain
ils sont assis pendant six ans
aujourd'hui il donne une leçon de
manifestations jeudi aujourd'hui les
gilets jaunes bien mal ce qui s'est
passé en algérie et les images qu'on a
pu voir c'est franchement c'est matt
c'est magique pour hiller mais
simplement reculées où il a vu arriver
la fin de son septennat quand même chose
à [ __ ] je pense que le gouvernement et
j'étais convaincu de sa au départ et je
le suis toujours
il ne recule pas par la violence il
recule par le monde par la masse en
soutien a le soutien moi je rêverais
d'une manif des gilet jaune le samedi
avec des familles des poussettes des
papilles des années donc déjà comme ça
selon le câble sous la
cela est évident qu'il serait dans la
rue mais ça veut dire qu'ils ne
soutiendraient pas non mais
bessane yalda mais à canal j'ai beaucoup
et il faut les maxima qui m'ont tous
mais là c'est les mêmes faces manivelle
c'est ça le truc que bagnols les
censures russie salue jack daniel's
l'algérie vous étiez pas loupé daniel 1
samedi et par ailleurs le dimanche a
oscillé alors ne parlez pas tous
amateurs avertis bercoff vidéo ça monte
puis faire revenir à ça d'abord juste
une chose pour l'algérie
ça prouve que les peuples quels qu'ils
soient car ils en ont marre de quelque
chose ils descendent dans la rue mais
qu'en est il des semble simplement il
faut le voir pour le moment
malheureusement ils voulaient une
élection ça allait aller ils ont pas
d'élection avec goûter encore mais
pourra lire ah ça va venir
les jaunes qui changent il faut revenir
à ça la france des jeunes et jaune
sait on à la parler mais il faut revenir
là dessus c'est cette moitié des
français qui ont été effectivement
licencié
je dis bien qui a eu un plan social de
masse de toute la france dit
périphériques on en a beaucoup parlé
déjà si on était bien attendez vous vous
ne vous intéressez pas vous vous êtes la
périphérie vous êtes les petites filles
les petits ouvriers et petits artisans
les petits commerçants tout ça vous le
faites plus les métropoles productive
possible par il faut pas dire on est
tous chez les jaunes
bernard laporte c'est pas vrai on n'est
pas touché les jeux moi j'suis pas gilet
jaune
moi je suis dans une evo tous ici
pratiquement on est dans la dans la
métropole
hall est un très très bon taux a aucune
culpabilité là dessus simplement les
autres ils ont été lésés côté et qui
attendait que ces gens là prennent 0
points prennent la rue monde est
d'accord et moi on a fait ce départ ici
même s'il vous plaît nous trouvâmes et
vous voulez pas la violence physique
c'est exactement ce que fait nicolas
réseau et arrivons là dessus on pose la
question les black blocks ont ils tué
mouvant j'aimerais qu'on parle à antonio
qui est un gilet jaune comme d'hab
énormément reçu ici au combat d'un micro
s'il vous plaît en route pour les black
blocs avaient pas s'intéresser aux qu'on
va parler est ce qu'on va dire avec
antonio larreta de acte iii wells a tué
le mouvement on est au 18 bon bah là
vous avez des violences non mais l'autre
millions saison car tony tony parker
jeunes à quel moment le gouvernement a
lâché à quel moment le gouvernement a
lâché 13 milliards d'euros pour les plus
fragiles alors qu'il disait que c'était
impossible la semaine avant donc je veux
chanter pour légèrement après l'acte iii
vous plaît on ne vous sert à karim
zéribi on se calme on vous macro juste
avant l'acte iii je ne changerai pas la
taxe carbone juste avant l'acte iii donc
à un moment où on est tous les
spécialistes politologue là qui pensent
donner des leçons au monde entier en
disant moi je sais comment il faut faire
pour se mobiliser
bougez vous organisez vos manifestations
défendez comme le fait maxime nicole les
plus fragiles de ce pays qui devaient
former bernard laporte et de son jeu
fait sarkozy bernard laporte être à la
botte de mélanger et contraints de se
garer ici derrière après avoir été mise
de sarkolâtres hasard elle abuse entendu
ça vous avez qu on veut faire comme ça
ça vous gêne t il alors que vous parlez
comme sa maxi nicole répond alors calmez
vous pourquoi
on se calme s'il vous plaît il croit pas
trop moi j'ai une question à vous
mettiez des primaires il ya quelques
mois ce que c'étaient des gars que tu
étais encore intérimaire ya trois mois
tu peux pas être là et c'est aujourd'hui
ça n'a en fait tu ça fait ça fait cinq
mois que je ne pose plus puisque je suis
dans soit d'accord et ensuite suite à un
changement de réformes de la salle est
pas finir tu me pose une question d'opel
et suite à un changement de réformes de
l'anpe
j'ai 750 heures qui ont sauté faux 610
heures à pouvoir le chômage donc du coup
je suis pas admissible au chômage et
comme j'ai un enfant et que ma femme
travaille el fallah plus maintenant
puisqu'elle est en accidents de travail
on lui a arraché un bout de doigt
dommage ça arrive et ben du coup pas
droit au chômage pas le droit au rsa bat
ça fait que j'aie la ssc combien c'est
le montant de la ssr et ce à moins que
ce que tu touches mais ressent parce que
moi - rsa tu vois il doit être de 200
quelques euros parce que j'ai aussi
l'allocation familiale
j'ai pas d'allocation fin au sort si on
perd on s'en fout pas alors entonné au
sang froid de cesser faut qu'on en parle
mais je reste atone yoplait calme allez
ça suffit là haut
antonio j'ai une question à poser parce
qu'on a vu l'interview du black block
moi la question mais moi je veux juste
dire quelque chose c'est qu'en fait je
suis horrifiée par tout ce qui se passe
parce que vous nous parlez d'un samedi
comme on a vécu
ouais mais là moi ce que je suis en
train de vivre c'est pitoyable vous
madame qui arrivait avec votre j'ai cinq
enfants chez une femme raisonnable et au
bout de dix minutes on apprend que vous
êtes un foulard rouge
ok tu la vends cacher ça c'est bien vous
cacher je vous assumez pas votre travail
c'est le cas pour le devoir de ramener
ne pas regarder comment vous êtes
agressif vous êtes comme ça dans les
maintenir ce n'est d'autre à dire que je
me cache dans mon taxi flash et si
l'accord se fait chez moi de venir
parler dans les médias oui il ya quoi
demander alors pourquoi vous vous
occupez pas dans le choix des vingt
personnes qui sont morts chez vous vous
ferez lèvres
il faudra tout ça monsieur maintenant on
va bien sûr il existe plusieurs parents
j'aimerais bien vous voir le samedi mon
avis vous êtes aussi agressif
c'est pas le navire bleu réserve c'est
important d'avoir quelqu'un qui il était
en devoir de réserve à ce soir antonio
voilà je n'ai pas avec le vice caché
quand je vends manifestation je répète
qu'un visage caché 2 eric naulleau et
maxime nicole le tout à l'heure tu
parles de la loi et vit avec un visage
caché ensuite il voudrait que rien de
regarder son première des deuxièmes voix
si voix la crise et nombre de dossiers
reçus sur les réseaux tachiyama gueule
sur les ménages qui pris en photo
beaucoup cette vulgaire monsieur non
parce que ça m'énerve ce genre de
comportement très nerveux
la preuve un peu vous énerve j'ose pas
vous imaginer le samedi ça doit être
pire si jamais vous avez vous une
demoiselle pour vous défendre c'est déjà
bien à l'aller calme et beau garçon se
désole quand j'ai des papiers sont
lâches effectivement quand j'entends
ceux des jours de discours ça m'énerve
mais cela dit c'est que vous allez droit
de porter une arme bon excusez moi moi
je pense que vous pouvez laisser passer
tonio on enlève ton micro pour l'instant
on se calme c'est sûr que non mark
jacqueline armes
ldb c'est une arme wind of wind of wind
et mine de rien n'était ces messages de
votre arme et audrey andrée calme toi
merci
l'émission fait un tonneau s'il te plaît
moi j'ai lu un truc
et tu sais que on s'entend bien tous les
deux bien je m'entends bien avec tout le
monde même les forces de l'ordre quand
ils sont réglo non mes amis je suis fier
tammy je suis fier que ce qu'il fait des
black blocks fulham dit wilson autres me
louis et je sais dire ça jean reno est
mba développer s'il tombe d'accord nous
parmi nous il ya que des trouillards
faut le dire il faudrait dire aux âges
et les jeux sont des trouillards
il arrive devant une vitrine il sauf on
se fait et j'ai comme des lapins
non mais là on a des gens cégep à être
des trouillards ça c'est pas des
trouillards sa cellule parce que j'adore
avoir des revendications sociales sont
pas venus pour casser des mini dévissé
ville et s'y mêler à la bagarre civile
six chiens juste m'exprimer je dis que
nous sommes des trouillards
je le vois depuis 18 semaines la seule
façon dont le gouvernement aujourd'hui
essaient de nous écouter c'est connais
des gens qui viennent [ __ ] la merde je
suis désolé le seul façon en fait qu'ils
ont que le gouvernement nous écoute pour
le chemin qu'on revienne à l'écouté
il ya eu la merde à paris moi je vais le
dire un truc cantonaux pas franchement
maxime c'est bon tu as est entendu là
2000 $ giuly vega moi je vous dis un
truc
eric ce qui me revient les gens savent
que je vous ai soutenu au début j'étais
le premier à vous inviter ce bateau teh
je vois un mec comme toi il ya des mecs
dans la rue qui me dit cyril hanouna
moi je vous le dit les gilet jaune je
peux plus les blairer bah je vous dis et
ça c'est à cause de trucs que j'ai vu
samedi
moi ça me fait de la peine quand
j'entends ça parce que je connais les
mecs qui sont derrière les chimistes on
ne se connait beaucoup je connais
beaucoup de mecs qui sont difficulté qui
veulent qu'un truc c'est que ça
s'arrange pour eux et moi quand
j'entends le plus en plus de gens parce
qu'au début quand je sortais tout le
monde me dit oui les gilet jaune
formidable est vraiment bravo ce que
vous faites pour ligier jaune deuxième
semaine luis a commencé à baisser là
aujourd'hui je te le dis dans la rue
combien de gens qui me disent tir il a
oui vous jouez bien mais attention les
gilet jaune moi je peux plus libéré
j'en peux plus des filets jonathan
l'histoire était sarda il ya encore plus
de gens qui peuvent plus béret macron
non mais son fils john et points ouais
mais tu es chez toi
non mais maxime daniel mois sauf que
l'âme sauf que quand on me dit oui
les gilets rouges peu plus libéré je
vous le dis synthèse d'ajouter il en
syrie la taille des civils mais moi je
ne circule pas des multi que ce soit la
seule chose qui me fait mal au coeur
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ça fait dix-huit
semaines
eux ils ont créé en marche et nous on a
créé les marcheurs à ce jour ça n'a rien
changé alors oui mais attristé de
renault je suis à mon statut songerait
les black blocs se tirent dessus je peux
pas dire sur le bloc ne s'est pas un mec
comme ça t'es pas un mec violente agit
pas des dieux mayas aucune vidéo où on
verra cas c'est parce que c'est pas mon
truc
pourquoi que l'amour est violent mais
parce qu'en fait c'est le ressenti de la
majorité des gens avec qui j'ai discuté
malheureusement ce que le gouvernement
nous écoute à ce jour il a fallu de la
casse s'il n'y a pas de casse on nous
écoute pas malheureusement se seraient
tous les casseurs ont-ils tué le
mouvement dix jeunes alésiens eric
naulleau faites vous plaisir grâce et
christiane crédit ne demanderait pas où
vous étiez je n'ai pas envie de savoir
merci on verra des photos de vous en
boîte de nuit demain bien sûr sur les
journaux people
aucun risque oui c'est ça regardez ce
qu'on pense les téléspectateurs oui à
46% non à 54% pour la majorité des
personnes donc les casseurs n'ont pas
tué le mouvement des gilets jaunes